so reality check now the fight against
covet california was the first state to
shut down entirely
about a year ago while florida basically
over time stayed open
the end result their case rate stayed
virtually the same the new york times
reporting that life in the sunshine
state looks like a return to normal
dr mark siegel professor of medicine nyu
langone medical center fox news
contributor dr day to you and good
morning
here is the unemployment rate in
california 9.0 percent
florida is 4.8 here is what axios writes
l.a times california versus florida who
handled it better
florida's pandemic response gets a
second look from the national media so
then
that's why we bring you in today compare
the two
what do you think is there something to
it
there's a it's a great comparison to
make because both have good weather
both have a lot of outdoor opportunities
california this
made me really suspicious back in
november closed
outdoor dining bill at a time when
restaurants had put a lot of money into
their outdoor footprint and there was
almost no spread and i knew that that
was the politics of fear
lockdowns are very problematic because
they have tremendous
mental physical and economic costs as
you know and the benefit has not really
been proven
once the virus is already spreading
through the community because
that's when masking and distancing and
less gatherings work
but if the if the virus is in your
household already locking down only
suffocates the situation it doesn't
prevent spread look at florida
florida under governor desantis has been
wide open the case numbers are about the
same
hospitalizations by the way have gone
down about 22 percent
and deaths 37 over the past two weeks in
florida
how could that be happening at a time
when the b-117
united kingdom variant which is wildly
contagious is over 50 percent of the
cases in florida
how could it be happening one we have a
lot of natural immunity there of people
who have already gotten coveted
and gotten over it we're not talking
about that immunity enough and
two the elderly population is getting
vaccinated big time in florida
over 60 already have had at least one
dose combination of vaccination
and natural immunity has been driving
down cases and outdoors
well let me have you listen to governor
ronda sanchez he was on with our judge
jeanine on saturday night
talking about his approach we viewed
this as a virus that was
particularly dangerous for elderly
people but not as dangerous for younger
people
we banned hospitals from sending
infected patients into nursing homes we
also did things
like prioritize our seniors for
vaccinations but
we had kids in school we also saved the
economy from collapse
our unemployment rate right now is 4.9
percent
so lessons learned perhaps governor
siegel
dr siegel this is what i would call sex
governors
thank you thank you i love it
listen this is what i'm calling settled
science he's right about the schools
he was visionary with the school schools
show less spread among kids than if the
kids
are out in the community also governor
desantis intervened at nursing homes
early on
with more protective equipment more
communication between families and
and loved ones who were in nursing homes
all of that was visionary but i still
think
masking distancing play a role here i'm
a little bit nervous about spring break
occurring
i don't think that we can just you know
put our guard down completely at this
point there's still a lot of cases
but the approach of opening businesses
is
clearly the way to go in the pandemic
when he's now been shown scientifically
doc what is your view of these variants
they're getting so much media attention
now
um when you consider how much concern
should there be
versus maybe the fear
of what could be there i think it's the
politics of fear i think
the word variant scares people i think
the word mutation
scares people do we need to pay
attention to it yes but listen bill
florida again
is a real world laboratory they've got a
lot of the uk
strain and yet the cases numbers are
going down hospitalization's going down
deaths are going down texas has removed
the mass mandate cases numbers are still
going down
we got to watch the variants very
carefully if we keep the number of virus
around down we're going to have less
variance but the vaccines
that we have cover pretty much every
variant that's out there right now
and if if need be we can always retool
the vaccine quickly
if a variant emerges we weren't
expecting we can get control of this
situation we're definitely heading in
the right direction
i do not predict a third wave the way
that europe is experiencing right now we
have had too much immunity here do you
think that europe is overreacting on the
astrazeneca vaccine and shutting all of
that down
or making the right decision i think
caution is the word here in fda dana has
been cautious about the astrazeneca
vaccine but let's keep in mind
you know how many thousands of people
get blood clot from covet 19
versus a few cases here we have to
always compare
what are the risks of the vaccine versus
the risks of the virus
the risks of the virus are enormous but
it's right to be
taking a close look at this they're
overreacting shutting it down yes
one last point here on fluid in
california
one of these experts said say the
epidemiology they're making the case
that
florida and california neither was right
or wrong
is that the epidemiologist focused only
on infection and immortality and that
was the mistake
infection and death rate do you agree
with that
i agree with that i think the thing we
focus on as public health people
is hospitalization rate are are they
getting in the way of our ability to
take care of other patients
that's why i think florida is ultimately
right if you get to the point
where you overwhelm your hospitals the
way we did in new york in march then you
do need a temporary
halt to everything to decrease the the
number of hospitalizations
that's the key figure by the way guys
here's my new model i want you to see
what i'm carrying around with me these
days
did you make that yourself that's true
no somebody sent this to me and look
look at the spike protein is accurate i
have to tell you
all right it's very nice looks like
thank you
bobblehead very good stuff there